so tonight I want to walk through some
of my favorite images that tell this
story that show you what is going on
right now and what it looks like in an
entirely new perspective
so to start harvest this is
deforestation in Bolivia what you see on
the left is the rainforest that has been
cut down and cleared to raise animals
and to do mechanized agriculture so when
I see this image I'm not just thinking
about the food but the earth that is
sacrificed to get our food it's a very
powerful moment there in the center you
can see that single cut right perhaps a
sign of what's to come or perhaps an
opportunity to save it I think it's very
easy to sit in a place like San
Francisco and say save the rainforest
save the rainforest but when you see an
image like this I think you contemplate
that there are people on the ground on
the left side of the screen who have
families to feed who are trying to make
money and there is a country of Bolivia
who needs food right so you can really
think about this for a long time what is
happening how do we preserve the
rainforest and also make sure that
people are getting the things they need
to live the lives they want these are
canola flowers in lieu of pink County
China yes it is actually that color
thinking about these beautiful
landscapes and also the byproducts of
the oils that are created from doing it
palm oil is another one that is
particularly detrimental to the
environment another image also from
China
this shows aquaculture so these are nets
and cages used to grow the fish that is
being used and consumed on a massive
scale where we extract so all of the
things that we have have to come from
somewhere right if you have a dishwasher
or a refrigerator that is made of
stainless steel it most likely came from
an iron ore mine like this one in the
Pilbara region of Australia ninety-eight
percent of the world's iron ore is used
to make seamless steel so you can see
this beautiful and scary scar that
creates things we use on
every day basis and oil oil has to be
extracted from the ground it's old
shells this is oil extraction on land at
the Dury field in Indonesia we also get
it from the above with platforms of
above water this is the manifold field
in Saudi Arabia one of the largest in
the world and that oil is then used for
energy where we power some of that oil
might go to this refinery in Ulsan South
Korea this is the third largest in the
world and has a capacity of 1.2 million
barrels of oil every single day where we
live we can learn a lot about the places
we live when we look at them from the
overview perspective there's a
particularly interesting example here
this is the Bay Area in the left you see
East Palo Alto on the right you see Palo
Alto when you look at areas and you look
at the amount of vegetation and green
space that they have you can gauge their
wealth this is a particularly
interesting example where you can see
them both in one frame but then when you
compare images like this one of the
slums of Delhi India where Green is not
detectable whatsoever to the affluent
suburbs of Copenhagen Denmark where
everyone has their own private growing
patch in their own green space in their
own huge front yard you have a new
understanding of the places that we live
where we move so we have these amazing
cities and then we create this
infrastructure to move under through
over them a particularly beautiful
example here in the Bay Area's the
Golden Gate Bridge which I will show in
every presentation ever for the end of
time or the Kansai Airport which is
constructed as an island in water it
looks like it's floating there like a
spaceship millions and millions of
dollars into these infrastructure travel
projects or these beautiful massive oil
tankers and shipping container ships
waiting outside the entry to the port of
Singapore one of the largest facilities
of its kind in the world where we design
so we have these cities and we're
thinking about
can we create something that's efficient
and flexible and also the buildings that
we've built to make them architecturally
sound we've been doing this for a while
these are the pyramids in Giza on some
of the early examples of design on a
massive form into the modern cities of
Europe like this one of Paris where you
can see the diagonal avenues radiating
from the Arc de Triomphe at the upper
left or the canals of Amsterdam which
was a particularly thoughtful and
beautiful city when seen from above and
then there's art just on a massive scale
for beauty sake this this is a guitar
forest with a particularly beautiful
story it was built by a father and his
children to honor his wife and their
mother who passed and she always loved
guitars and she never had one and they
built this in her honor we also like to
have fun right it's not all waste and
mining and we enjoy the world and we
enjoy our time in it so we build spaces
to enjoy the world this is Central Park
in the midst of our city in New York we
also do it in natural environments -
this is Aspen Snowmass you can see the
ski trails carved out into the side of
the mountain and also on the natural
environment of coral reef this is Bora
Bora and you can see the bungalows that
hotels and resorts have built out into
the perfect blue waters now all of the
buckets that I've talked through already
they don't really just end there they're
often byproducts or things that come of
these systems so where do we waste right
you saw those massive ships when they
are decommissioned they are often sent
to a place like this in Bangladesh this
is a ship breaking yard where people
working in horrible conditions use
explosions and old tools to scrap the
ships for parts all of the cities that
we live in have a lot of people who are
creating a lot of trash this is a
massive landfill in South Korea part of
which is filled to capacity the other
part is seen to be filled to capacity
but we have to think about this one
statistic that says the wealthy you are
the more trash you generate that is very
much seen in these massive landfills in
these major cities the last chapter
where we are not there are still places
believe it or not where humans have not
yet impacted the landscape when you look
at this Red Lake in Tanzania or the
perrito Moreno glacier in Argentina and
Patagonia or this massive desert of sand
dudes called The Empty Quarter in Saudi
Arabia you're seeing landscapes which
formed over thousands of years tens of
thousands of years hundreds of thousands
millions of years deep time right and
when you compare that amount of time to
the development scene in the previous
eight chapters things that we've built
in the past 5 10 20 years you not only
see how much we're doing to the planet
you see how quickly we are doing to it
so this chapter serves as a comparison
to show you that the earth has been
around a lot longer than we have and it
will be around a lot longer after we're
gone